[Musique]
l'argonaute c'est le nouveau complexe
sportif et culturel du quartier de
l'argonne à orléans il a ouvert ses
portes en septembre 2017
on y pratique une quarantaine de
disciplines
ça fait pas longtemps que ça existe
l'argonaute alors qu'est ce que tu en
penses toi de ce nouveau bâtiment
c'est un très beau bâtiment
il ya des très belles salles moi je
trouve c'est une belle salle de sport
mais jamais vu cela mais avant c'est
tout nouveau et moderne
les danseuses de hip hop sont pile à
l'heure pour leurs cours à l'argonaute
par les cours il y en avait un peu
partout sur la métropole n'est pas
encore dans le quartier de l'argonne
et pourtant le break dancing nous on
croyait que ça pouvait se danser
n'importe où ça se danse n'importe où
mais c'est vrai que pour donner un cours
c'est important d'avoir l'outil du
miroir pour que l'on puisse se corriger
et puis que ça soit dans de bonnes
conditions pour pour les enfants qui
sont accueillis le hip hop apparu dans
les années 70 aux états unis est devenue
la culture urbaine dominante de par le
monde et pour les jeunes danseuses
c'était une évidence de s'y essayer
je voulais savoir ce qu'ils te plaisait
dans no et auxerre veut dire mais j'aime
tout la gestion et enfin soria trop cuit
aux aime trop ça
début je voulais pas j'étais un peu
timide mais c'est ma mère en fait que je
fasse est ce qu'en fait je pense tout le
temps la mise en scène un petit point
noir
pour apprendre les street dancers sont
entre de bonnes mains avec la vice
championne de france 2010 est par
équipes
elodie a 22 ans et déjà huit ans de
pratique de up derrière elle elle s'est
initiée en participant à des stages dans
le quartier de l'argonne avant de se
former en france et à l'étranger
pas seulement pour moi c'est bien parce
que j'ai commencé à en prendre ici donc
le fait de pouvoir en donner ici aussi
c'est la continuité et et avec les cours
on essaie de transmettre un peu plus que
juste des chorégraphies on va être
enceinte vraiment sain d'esprit et la
compétition c'est après partie du hip
hop
donc nous en tant que prof on y
participe et pourquoi pas plus dans les
lettres